[Música]
özil experimentos sobre man este país
bien la mayoría de personas
pero porque que hizo japón tan especial
que obviamente toda una generación
generaciones atrás y diversiones de
antes
pero en la universidad en el mismo
acierto exterior de eeuu
los dos me dio la oportunidad de
exportar un pasatiempo a una oportunidad
de explorar su país de la dimensión
única arraigada a sus experiencias
culturales ya sea como una vida sencilla
como tirar esto necesita con complicadas
también por primera vez el potencial que
tenía unir dos industrias que nunca se
habían encontrado como lo es la
industria
emprendedor todas las penurias que
pasamos de como no hay financiamiento de
como los posibles clientes desconocen de
nuestro producto y de sus ventajas
hoy como incluso hasta mi mamá no cree
que sea posible vivir de esto pero la
verdad yo creo que no estaría
agregándole ningún valor porque
emprender siempre es difícil sin
importar en la industria en la que
encontremos siempre en las que nos
encontremos siempre va a ser difícil por
lo cual yo les traigo
yo los desafío a que así como japón
rompamos esa arquitectura mental que
tenemos sobre la industria de los
videojuegos y todos los paradigmas que
la rodean estamos hablando de una
industria que sólo el año pasado hizo
100 billones a nivel mundial de los
cuales 5 millones provienen de pequeños
estudios latinoamericanos presentándose
un crecimiento registrado del 20 por
ciento anual el cual es un crecimiento
el más grande y rápido de una región
relacionada al entretenimiento
los grandes postores lo saben los
grandes postores como sony nintendo y
microsoft saben la importancia que tiene
innovar que tiene la creatividad en esta
industria por lo cual ellos han puesto
sus miradas en los mercados emergentes
como latinoamérica brindando
herramientas como kits de desarrollo
licencias tutorías mentorías con los
mejores de la industria todo esto para
facilitarnos la apuesta de contenido en
sus plataformas ya han visto historias
de éxito con pequeños estudios de menos
de 50 personas creando juegos
multimillonarios como países de
escandinavia como lo es clash royal
angry birds o minecraft que estoy seguro
que más de uno lo tiene descargado en su
celular pero
aquí es donde se encuentra headless
chicken game un pequeño estudio
costarricense de 5 personas que buscan
enviar su marca país mediante una visión
meramente arraigada a nuestra cultura
del mundo en playstation y en realidad
virtual desgraciadamente la mayoría de
costarricenses y de latinoamericanos
creemos que es imposible competir contra
los japoneses contra los estadounidenses
no podemos un estudio tan pequeño no
puede contra las grandes potencias
mientras que paradójicamente estas
grandes potencias son las que están
facilitando todo para que logremos poner
contenido ahí
la industria de los videojuegos no sólo
trae ventajas a los que nos encontramos
en ella gracias al alto contenido que
tiene esta tecnología e innovación
brinda un nicho para que logramos crear
y exportar nuevas tecnologías servicios
fuertes como la minería de datos como el
mercado digital como los los videojuegos
empresariales sociales y educativos
si hemos logrado exportar grandes
maestros gastronómicos maestros
literarios maestros en artes visuales
por quiero pensar en que podemos
exportar el nuevo
supermario es completamente posible ya
los grandes estamos así lo están
haciendo creen en nosotros cambio a
nivel local estamos tan cerca que no lo
podemos ver yo los instó a que le demos
una oportunidad al contenido creado en
esta región ya que así con la industria
de los videojuegos tenemos todo un
puente para desarrollar el gran
potencial que tiene latinoamérica como
industria exportadora de arte y
tecnología muchas gracias
[Aplausos]